Traduttore: Stefania Buoni
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Cosa vuol dire essere
un "giovane caregiver?"
Quando una persona cara
inizia a star male
l'attenzione è tutta su quella persona,
sui suoi bisogni.
Ma se quella persona
che ha qualcosa che non va
è tua mamma o tuo papà cosa accade?
Cosa accade a te se quando mamma o papà
o entrambi iniziano a star male
sei ancora un bambino o un adolescente?
Quand'ero un'adolescente
non avevo la più pallida idea
di essere una "giovane caregiver".
Come tutti andavo a scuola,
ridevo e scherzavo con gli amici.
Ma cosa c'è, dietro a queste foto,
che non si vede?
Prima di raccontarvi
la parte nascosta dell'iceberg
vorrei fare un passo indietro,
ricominciare dal principio.
Se vi chiedessi cosa è cambiato
e cosa è rimasto uguale,
probabilmente, a parte l'età,
mi direste che amo ancora i cani
e ho cambiato taglio di capelli.
Ma cosa c'è di invisibile
in quelle foto?
Che cosa mi ha portato
dalla me bambina che vedete al centro
alla me adulta che sono oggi,
passando per la me adolescente
che vedete a sinistra?
A un certo punto uno tsunami
ha investito la mia famiglia.
Uno tsunami che è cresciuto
progressivamente, fino a travolgerla.
Uno tsunami chiamato problema di salute.
E quando colpisce uno o entrambi
i tuoi genitori
e tu sei ancora un bambino
o un adolescente
loro sono i tuoi punti di riferimento
diventa davvero complicato.
E se vi dicessi
che il problema di salute
è un problema di "salute mentale"?
Il carico per un figlio
può essere molto pesante
e può essere fatto di sensi di colpa,
paura, rabbia, tristezza,
amore e odio
che si alternano vorticosamente,
la sensazione costante
di camminare sulle uova,
un carico eccessivo di responsabilità,
la difficoltà a concentrarsi
e anche il doversi occupare
di faccende domestiche,
come fare la spesa o badare
a fratellini e sorelline più piccole,
o parlare con i medici
e gestire la terapia.
Oppure essere vittima di bullismo,
magari a causa dei comportamenti bizzarri
che il tuo genitore potrebbe avere.
Ma in aggiunta a questo
potresti dover gestire
delle vere e proprie emergenze,
per le quali nessuno ti ha preparato.
Come gestire la situazione
mentre tuo padre o tua madre
vede o sente cose che non esistono:
le psicosi.
O dover aver a che fare con l'alternarsi
di stati maniacali e depressivi
senza che nessuno ti abbia
preparato a farlo.
O addirittura assistere o sventare
tentativi di suicidio.
Ma in aggiunta a tutto questo,
dovendo poi continuare
anche a fare la vita di sempre,
andare a scuola, studiare...
il motivo per cui sono qui oggi
è che si aggiunge un altro carico
che è spesso il non poterne parlare
con nessuno.
Se dici che tua mamma o tuo papà
hanno un problema di salute fisica,
un tumore o un'altra patologia fisica,
difficilmente qualcuno
li colpevolizzerà per questo
o li riterrà dei cattivi genitori
o delle persone deboli.
Difficilmente qualcuno considererà te
come geneticamente compromesso
e destinato in automatico
a ereditare lo stesso disturbo.
Ma se provi a dire che tua mamma
o tuo papà hanno una depressione maggiore,
un disturbo bipolare o una schizofrenia,
o se non c'è neanche una diagnosi,
a descrivere il loro comportamento
e dire: "mamma o papà
hanno qualcosa che non va",
la risposta del mondo esterno
sarà completamente diversa.
Ancora oggi in tutto il mondo
la salute fisica e la salute mentale
non godono
della stessa dignità e rispetto.
Ancora oggi non è percepita
come un bene comune
che appartiene a tutti noi.
E questo comporta un ritardo
nel capire cosa accade
dentro di sé e ai propri cari,
un ritardo a chiedere e ricevere aiuto,
o spesso a non ricevere affatto
una cura.
E per te che sei figlio
il carico diventa ancora più pesante.
Il clima che percepisci intorno a te,
la difficoltà a comunicare
dentro e fuori la famiglia,
lo stigma, il pregiudizio, la vergogna
possono portarti a tenerti tutto dentro
e a non dire proprio niente.
Ma solitudine e silenzio sono un carico
pesante da portare per un minore.
Come facevo io ad affrontare
la situazione?
Cosa c'è dietro quelle foto
che non è visibile?
Dietro a quel sorriso?
C'era una corazza che si è venuta
a formare in automatico,
dietro la quale nascondevo,
una corazza di ghiaccio
che mi permetteva di tener dentro
paura, rabbia e dolore
ed evitare che travolgessero me
e le persone che avevo intorno,
e mi permetteva di continuare
a fare le cose di tutti i miei coetanei
ma che allo stesso tempo
mi faceva sentire distante
anni luce da loro,
perché mi aveva fatto crescere
prima degli altri.
Allo stesso tempo
c'era anche un grido di aiuto
un grido di aiuto che non poteva,
che non riusciva a uscire
e che nessuno,
neanche a scuola, immaginava.
Quando la prima crepa ha iniziato
ad aprirsi in quella corazza?
Quando per la prima volta
la luce ha iniziato a filtrare?
Ricordo ancora con affetto
la psicologa del consultorio familiare
che è la prima persona fidata
fuori dalla famiglia
con la quale ho potuto aprirmi
e che mi ha aiutato piano piano
a individuare persone fidate
intorno a me, la rete estesa,
che potessero essermi di supporto.
Ma il vero e proprio spartiacque
è stato per me
l'aver letto in Internet su dei forum
le storie di altri figli di altri paesi,
grazie all'amore per le lingue
che mi avevano trasmesso i miei genitori.
Le storie di noi figli di genitori
con disturbo mentale
sono tutte diverse, tutte uniche.
Ma c'è una cosa che mi ha colpito
e che abbiamo in comune.
È che spesso siamo convinti
di essere gli unici.
Ma è statisticamente impossibile!
Nel mondo siamo milioni di persone.
Eppure ci convinciamo di esserlo,
che non ci sia nessun altro
che abbia vissuto le stesse cose
che abbiamo vissuto noi.
E sapete perché accade?
Perché delle nostre storie di figli
non parliamo.
Attraverso le storie di figli attivisti,
provenienti da Australia, USA e Canada,
non solo ho potuto dare un nome
a delle emozioni che avevo provato
e capire che erano una naturale
reazione a quello che avevo vissuto,
ma ho potuto anche vedere
le caratteristiche positive
che erano nate proprio per far fronte
a quella situazione.
E quindi ho preso il mio primo volo
intercontinentale, da sola
e sono andata a Vancouver, in Canada,
per la prima conferenza in cui ho parlato,
per incontrarli, questi figli,
per parlare con loro.
Ed è stato un momento
di rispecchiamento positivo potentissimo
perché in loro ho visto la storia
che avevo vissuto,
ma anche quella ancora da scrivere.
In loro ho visto il dolore,
ma anche la capacità di riscatto,
di trasformare quel dolore
in semi per un cambiamento.
Ho visto quelle caratteristiche positive
di resilienza, empatia, coraggio,
volontà di cambiare lo status quo
che non riconoscevo in me,
ma che vedendole riflesse in loro
ho finalmente sentivo anche mie.
Quell'incontro è stato un dono,
un dono immenso,
che mi dà energia ancora adesso.
Ed è un dono che io ho voluto fortemente
riportare in Italia, in Europa
per aiutare altri "forgotten children",
altri figli dimenticati
a poter togliere dei pesi
dalle loro spalle.
Il desiderio è che nessun bambino,
adolescente o giovane adulto
debba più sentirsi solo quando
uno o entrambi i genitori
iniziano a soffrire
di un disturbo psichico.
È un desiderio immenso,
che ha bisogno dell'aiuto di tutti
perché, altrimenti, come non rischiare
ancora una volta,
di caricare il peso del mondo
tutto sulle mie spalle?
Ed è così che arriviamo ad oggi.
Nel 2017, insieme ad altri figli italiani,
Gaia, Carlo e Marco,
abbiamo fatto nascere la prima
associazione italiana
creata da figli per altri figli
per dare voce a bambini e adolescenti
che non hanno una voce,
per far valere le nostre istanze
anche alle istituzioni
e si chiama COMIP,
Children of Mentally Ill Parents,
figli di genitori con disturbo mentale.
Abbiamo dato il via a un progetto
che si chiama
come la mini guida che ho scritto
e che avrei voluto avere fra le mani io
quando avevo quindici anni
e si chiama: "Quando Mamma o Papà
Hanno Qualcosa Che Non Va
miniguida alla sopravvivenza per figli
di genitori con disturbo mentale."
Ed è un progetto che è partito dal basso,
grazie al crowdfunding,
grazie all'aiuto di persone vicine a me,
alcune sono in questa sala adesso,
che hanno creduto
in questo stesso desiderio
e ci hanno dato linfa per farlo partire
e farlo svettare alto.
Questo progetto ha l'obiettivo ambizioso
di donare una copia di questa miniguida
a tutte le biblioteche scolastiche
e cittadine, a tutti i consultori
e ai centri di salute mentale
d'Italia
perché nessun ragazzo sia più
lasciato solo,
e neanche le loro famiglie.
Soprattutto i figli di genitori
che non sono consapevoli
del loro disturbo e non sono neanche
in cura per il loro disturbo.
Noi anche a questi ragazzi
dobbiamo pensare!
Io sono stata una di loro
per un periodo.
All'inizio quando ho pensato
questo progetto
mi sono detta: "Non ce la farò mai
a realizzarlo, come farò?"
Piano piano, però, ho chiesto aiuto
alle persone intorno a me,
anche alle guide escursioniste,
proponendo di raccontare
durante una passeggiata
in dieci minuti la storia
e trovare così persone
della società civile
che magari non hanno vissuto
questa esperienza
che sono voluti diventare i nostri
"postini del cambiamento"
e portare una copia della miniguida
in dono, da parte nostra,
alla biblioteca del loro comune.
E adesso siamo riusciti ad arrivare
in tantissime regioni,
dalla Val D'Aosta fino alla Sicilia
e alla Sardegna.
E non ci fermiamo,
vogliamo raggiungerle tutte.
Un altro desiderio che abbiamo
è quello di smuovere le istituzioni
a fare di più per noi, ma anche
la società civile,
e investire di più in salute mentale.
Un altro desiderio enorme
che stiamo realizzando
è quello di incontrare le scuole,
parlare con gli studenti, con i ragazzi.
Non soltanto i figli caregiver,
ma tutti.
Per poter avere una cassetta
degli attrezzi
per fare fronte alle emozioni
positive e negative,
alle sfide della vita
partendo attrezzati,
prima che si stia troppo male.
Per salvare le vite.
È un cammino lungo e tortuoso,
quello che abbiamo davanti,
ma se c'è una cosa che so
è che una delle caratteristiche positive
che noi figli di genitori
con un disturbo mentale abbiamo
è la volontà di cambiare
lo status quo.
Ed è per questo che so
che quella ragazza
ce la farà a realizzare il suo desiderio,
anche grazie a voi.
Se questa storia vi ha colpito,
vi ha emozionato,
parlatene, raccontatela
ai vostri amici, ai colleghi.
Apriamo insieme quella porticina
che per noi non si era aperta.
Facciamo entrare la Luce!
Grazie.
(Applausi)